hello everybody we did it we raised our
goal of $6,000 for Uno's the United
Network for Organ Sharing now if you're
like well wait a minute this line
doesn't say that it's oh yes it does
because I am going to be having 256
dollars of my own contribution to this
and that doesn't actually correlate with
the fact that there are 256 contributors
that's just a happy coincidence it's two
hundred dollars that I pledged at the
beginning plus 56 dollars that is added
because of t-shirt sales and I promise
that all sales would go towards all
profit that I make from those sales
would go towards the charity so here's a
charity the next page you see will be
the actual donation hello all right here
we are again at the Uno's donation page
I hope you can all can see this clearly
that's my name this all is blacked out
you can't see this so are you sorry
sorry but here is the exact number that
we are going to donate it's six thousand
one hundred and thirty two dollars and
ninety three cents to Uno's which is the
charity of United United Network for
Organ Sharing that's it and the rest of
this blocked out for obvious reasons and
we're gonna scroll very carefully so
that I can black out accordingly down to
the bottom scrolling scrolling trolling
trolling alright and here and
everything's blacked out still cell
sorry but here's the proceed to
verification button going on here
hopefully everything can turn out okay
aha okay more blacked out stuff but the
number is still there and bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
everything seems good let me get thee
and let me try to get the logo in there
yeah that's the United Network for Organ
Sharing donate life very very very
important stuff so thank you all for
this and here we go BAM
and just like that we have made the
donation this has been an incredible
moment thank you guys so much you don't
know what this means to me to know that
like we can do this stuff this is an
incredible thing and I'm really really
really glad that we can this is like the
bigger this is one of the biggest this
is the biggest donation we've only
almost doubled how much we've donated in
total like throughout the entire time
we've done charity donations and I bet
we could do more but we I want to save
you know donations for the next month
when next month we're gonna do another
charity we're gonna let you guys know
what charity we're raising money for so
thank you guys again this is this is
this is unbelievable that's over six
thousand dollars that's a huge amount of
money so thank you all so much for
helping out that we're gonna do this
again we're gonna keep doing it I know
we're gonna hit over 50,000 for the year
so thank you again and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]